[Music]
this is drew been hair reporting live
from the stat line games an average one
the final round of the X bar competition
is about to begin
the hometown favorite John Smith has
overcome incredible odds to beer today
he's the first average mountain ever to
reach the final round of an event at the
stat land games in Xtreme borrowing or X
barring for short
the competitor jumps as high as they can
and grabs on to the highest bar they can
reach if they grab bar J their score is
J their score is a discrete random
variable X before the jump we don't know
what X will be after the jump we observe
a specific value for X
there are several notions of average
that are used in statistics the most
widely used is called the mean or
expected value imagine a large number of
hypothetical jumps by John and tracking
how many times he achieved each possible
score say there were a thousand
independent jumps where bar seven eight
and nine were achieved four hundred five
hundred and 100 times respectively
the simple average of these outcomes can
be written as a weighted average of the
possible scores the weights 0.4 0.5 and
0.1 are non-negative numbers that add up
to one each score is weighted based on
the fraction of time and occurred in the
sample in general the expected value of
a discrete random variable X is the sum
of possible values times the
probabilities of those values a of x
equals the sum over X of x times the
probability that big x equals little X
each possible value of x gets weighted
according to its probability John how
did you get where you are today I grew
up in average me and was always told I
could never be more than average and
that the law of large numbers says it is
a mathematical certainty that in the
long run I would be just average but now
I realize I can change my average
through hard work and practice the
sample mean x-bar of random variables x1
through xn is their simple average the
sum of X J's divided by n the law of
large numbers says that for independent
random variables all from the same
distribution with mean mu the sample
mean converges to the theoretical mean
mu with probability 1 but John is right
that this does not preclude him from
improving over time his X barring
outcomes may be dependent and may have
distributions that change with time
and here's jump amazing we can also
think about the expected value of a
continuous random variable
through an X barring example let Y be
the highest point John reaches on a jump
we can think of X as a discretized
version of Y for example just now john
reached 11 point 2 3 9 4 . and then he
grabbed on to bar 11 if we imagine more
and more bars being filled in the
discrete random variable measuring which
bar was reached becomes a better and
better approximation to the continuous
random variable measuring the height
that john reached it then makes sense to
define the expected value of a
continuous random variable y as the
integral of y times the probability
density function of y from minus
infinity to infinity this is analogous
to the expected value of a discrete
random variable with an integral in
place of a sum and a PDF and place of a
probability and now for my personal
favorite event in the stat line games
the ski loop wire loop ski from
continued appleís one of the greatest
ski bloopers of all time is getting
ready to begin here she goes
it's always amazing to watch liar loop
ski ski loop and ski looping the
competitor skis down a mountain and then
360 degrees through a loop and then
straight through to the finish line
the T would be the time it takes to
reach the loop and T to be the
additional time needed to reach the
finish line so the overall time is T
equals t1 plus t2
lyra that was amazing I focus on the
fundamentals I make sure to get off to a
good start when reaching the loop since
that is highly correlated is how quickly
I can ski the loop Collin so how did ly
reloop ski do compared to what we
expected based on her past performances
oh I have a lot of data on that in the
past her average t1 time was two point
nine five seconds and her average t2
I was 4.0 five seconds what about her
average overall time the average of t1
plus t2 well I haven't had time to
compute that so yeah let's see
[Music]
Oh Colin you don't need to do all those
tedious calculations we only need to add
two numbers to get the average of T huh
the average of T is the average of T 1
plus the average of T 2 so live is
average overall time in the past was two
point nine five seconds plus four point
oh five seconds which is seven seconds
but but T 1 and T 2 are correlated yes
but since we're just adding up a bunch
of numbers it doesn't matter what order
we add them in expectation is one of the
most useful concepts in statistics not
only in its own right but also because
it's the key to defining many other
useful quantities such as standard
deviation and correlation Sylvia is
using the idea of linearity of
expectation which is an extremely
important property for any random
variables x and y even if they're
dependent the expected value of x plus y
is the expected value of x plus the
expected value of y as long as these
expectations exist linearity often lets
us break complicated expectations into
simpler pieces
you
you